Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Trolls, the latest film from DreamWorks Animation,
takes us on a journey through the world of
these all-hugging, all-singing, and all-dancing
cute little shiny happy creatures as they
try to avoid being captured by the extremely
gloomy ogre-like Bergens, who can only experience
happiness by gobbling up Trolls.
The story is quite straightforward and follows
an odd couple, the always cheery and optimistic
Poppy and the downbeat and ever-anxious Branch,
as they somewhat reluctantly set out together
to save their fellow brightly coloured beings
from ending up in the Bergens' stomachs.
With Pitch Perfect's Anna Kendrick voicing
Poppy, Justin Timberlake playing Branch, and
New Girl's Zooey Deschanel as the Bergen scullery
maid Bridget, the filmmakers would have been
mad not to make the most of their cast's singing
talents.
So, you can expect plenty of musical scenes
and song-and-dance numbers, the majority of
which fit pretty nicely within the tale being
told.
The toys the movie's based on were actually
popular at various points from the 1960s through
to the 90s, so fittingly the soundtrack is
mostly filled with tunes from those eras,
including some classic disco tracks and power
ballads, as well as some new pop songs.
If you like many of the songs which the cast
covers, then you'll likely find yourself in
a good mood and the right place to enjoy the
movie overall.
But it's the animation where the film really
shines.
There's an incredible tactile, textured quality
to the whole film, and particularly the Trolls
themselves.
Directors Mike Mitchell and Walt Dohrn and
their animators have really outdone themselves
capturing the felty, fuzziness of the Trolls
and their world, which is essentially a crazy
blast of colours and glitter.
And there's an especially lovely sequence
where Poppy wanders through the forest and
comes across all sorts of weird beasts and
plant life.
Sure, the story and characters don't have
the complexity or the wide range of pop culture
easter eggs we get from the likes of Pixar
or the best of Disney or Dreamworks itself.
And it's clear where Jonathan Aibel and Glenn
Berger's screenplay is going from the start.
And, yes, the movie does put its message front
and centre on several occasions.
Still, though we've seen characters like these
before and the story certainly borrows from
the likes of The Hobbit, Cinderella, and Cyrano
de Bergerac, or if you prefer Roxanne, the
movie is perfectly enjoyable, sweet, and decent
fun that moves along at a good pace and knows
to quit by the 90-minute mark while it's still
ahead.
Make no mistake: Trolls is squarely aimed
at younger kids, but there are some adult-tinged
moments, and the quality of the animation,
the music, and some of its humour means it
does have potential for adult audiences too.
And, of course, it's entirely possible some
grown-ups may identify with aspects of Branch's
less-than-rosy attitude to life, which, while
it makes him an outlier among his joy-filled
fellow Trolls, acts as a nice counterbalance
to the Trolls' never-ending wildly enthusiastic
nature, which some adults might find a little
jarring otherwise.
To sum up: Trolls creates a beautifully textured
fuzzy world packed with colour and sparkle.
The movie's clear storyline and simple message,
wrapped up in bright packaging, makes it ideal
for younger kids.
And while it's unlikely to make your list
of unforgettable films, it will likely keep
you and definitely any young ones entertained
while you're watching.
So, I'm giving Trolls 3 out of 5 Flicks.
Now, are you looking forward to the movie
Trolls, or if you've seen it, what did you
think?
And what are your favourite animations this
year so far?
Let me know in the comments below!
Coming up, I'll be reviewing sci-fi flick
Arrival, and I'll also be making videos on
the TV show Westworld and Disney's Moana.
If you enjoyed this video, do share it, and
subscribe for more movie reviews and crazy
movie and TV facts!
Click the links here to check those out!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!